what is up everybody welcome back to
another matplotlib tutorial and the
three dimensions and this one we're just
going to add on one more layer on top of
this scatter plot just to show a little
something cool that you can do with
scatter plots and then also you'll see
with like bar charts and stuff but
scatter plots it's really fun because
it's covenant in addition to machine
learning 3d three-dimensional plot it's
definitely helped machine learning
because if you think about it like I've
said before in some of my other videos
machine learning is really just machine
classification and it also starts
machine learning does with really
machine teaching right you have to teach
the Machine how it ought to learn kind
of like you know when you were in school
you had to be pot someone pot you study
techniques right and so it's the same
thing like we have to eventually teach
the computer study tactics in order for
it to actually do some machine learning
so anyway anyone who is interested in
machine learning should definitely check
out some other tutorials of mine there's
also some really cool machine learning
tutorials on YouTube anyway continuing
on and I'll probably actually have some
machine learning tutorials and the near
future it's the idea of it is very
intriguing anyway continuing on
3-dimensional scatter plots are really
useful for a machine learning because
some people will do it on a
two-dimensional plane but the problem
with the two-dimensional plane is you
have you know let's say you have a 20 by
20 graph you only have 400 positions
that you can consider for example when
you add another dimension well you're
you're adding another freaking dimension
alright so if you were 20 by 20 and you
added by 20
you're literally multiplying your
position possibilities by 20 otherwise
known as basically moving from 400
optional positions to now 8,000 optional
positions that you can consider for your
categorization so it makes a huge
difference when you can
look at maybe a multi-dimensional array
worth of data so it is beneficial but
sometimes you know at once you get a
good algorithm down you can start doing
that but sometimes it's useful for you
to be able to visualize it
so anyways enough chitchat let's do the
3d plotting of one of the addition to
what we had so let's say we're going to
do X as Y is Z s and now you might want
to change or you might want to add them
right to what you're plotting but now
you want to plot anything under this
variable select the way this would work
though is it say you were doing machine
learning it would be classifying stuff
in the real time so anything that was
classified under these specific
parameters would be thrown into this
array and then later you would you know
publish it for yourself so you can see
the results and see if your machine
learning algorithm is doing a good job
or not and so for this one we'll make
these scatter plots blue and they're
going to be carrot top it's denoted for
little triangles basically so now let's
just save that that's really the only
change we needed to make and let's plot
that and in fact it looks horrible what
did we do wrong let's see oh I know we
did I'm going to add a negative signs to
all this data so let me do that really
quick really need to just add a negative
sign to one of the pieces of data but
that's ok weird this we've gone this far
yes actually let's finish it off just
like this there we go say I make sure I
closed it I just don't want to get in
trouble with matplotlib
there we go part stood again dang it's
like still giving me this three deal
what do we do wrong ah man ok XS y is zs
man amateur anyways this is my first
rodeo
ok tie that we've got him in fact it
looks like it ought to be so for example
actually this would be an example of a
failed machine learning algorithm that
needs more work right as clearly if you
look at this there are three groups this
group this group in this group
only there's only one dividing line
which would be here but anyway this just
gives you the idea that you can have
different groups and group types on the
same scatter plot and use that for
classification it doesn't have to be
fair machine learning of course but it
can be intent anyway I just wanted to
add that to the arsenal of 3d plotting
tutorials and that's going to glued this
pretty quick and short video be really
short if I didn't react for so long
anyway as always thanks for watching
safety in the next video and thank you
for your support or subscriptions